(boom reverberates)
- Hello, Believe Nation.
Today I'm going to talk
about the seven ways
to start your perfect day.
♫ Nine
♫ Eight
♫ Seven
(upbeat electronic music)
- So I'm big believer in morning routines.
I think that if you
start your day off right,
it carries through to
the rest of your day.
But if you start your
day off wrong, negative,
missing your first thing,
whatever that first habit
is you're supposed to do,
if you miss that,
then you're likely to
cheat on the rest of it.
Right, like if you say
you're going to eat healthy,
and then you start by going to get
that really junky Starbucks
drink in the morning,
you're unlikely to be
healthy the rest of the day.
You're unlikely to follow through
on all the other goals you
said you were going to do.
So why it's so important
to have a morning routine
that sets you up for success.
This is probably the
topic of my next book,
or at least a good chunk of it.
I find a lot of people, once
they find their one word,
it's super helpful, it's really powerful.
But how do you make sure
that you live your one
word every single day?
And it comes from starting up
with a great morning routine.
Now these are seven strategies
I'm going to share with you today.
You don't necessarily have to
apply all of them to your life.
What I encourage you to do is
test one at a time for a week.
Just test adding this one thing
to your morning routine for the week.
And see, do you feel better?
Do you have more energy?
Was it a waste of time?
All you've lost is a few minutes
every day for one week, right?
But the upside is tremendous.
So test each one out,
and let me know which
one works best for you.
(hip hop music)
So the first way to start your
perfect day off is to get up.
Get rid of the snooze button.
Now while some of you may be
throwing tomatoes at me now,
or clicking away, you're
addicted to that snooze button.
Let's talk about some of the reasons why
you shouldn't be snoozing.
First off, science has proven
it's actually bad for you.
You actually feel a lot more groggy.
If you just hear the
alarm, and you get up,
you're much more likely to
have an energized morning.
Where if you snooze, and then you snooze,
your brain falls back asleep,
and then gets up, and then falls asleep,
and then gets back up again.
And while that may feel
good in the short term,
you're going to have a
couple hours of grogginess
that will not help you.
The other thing is on
a subconscious level,
you're training yourself to fail.
You're training yourself to say,
this is a goal that I had,
and I didn't do it, right?
My goal is to wake up at this
time, and I didn't do it.
I'm snoozing, I didn't do it.
I snooze again, I didn't do it again.
You're training yourself that it's okay
to set a goal for yourself for a new habit
and not follow through.
And this is how you're
starting every single day.
You're starting the
day by saying it's okay
to let myself down and
disappoint myself again.
That is not a powerful
way to start your day.
So that, combined with
the science, get up.
Put your clock somewhere
else across the room.
Whatever strategy you want
to use, it doesn't matter,
stop pressing the snooze
button, and just get up.
(hip hop music)
Number two, drink some water.
Your body is 60% water.
Your brain is 75% water.
One of the main reasons
why you're so tired
in the morning is you're dehydrated.
You've sweat a lot of water out overnight.
You've just been sleeping for five, six,
seven, eight, nine hours
without any hydration.
You need to get up and
not reach for coffee,
but reach for a glass of water.
It will make you feel better.
The science has proved it.
It's one of the most consistent things
that I think really
everybody should be doing
to give themselves more
energy in the morning.
On top of having more energy
and feeling less tired,
drinking water will help you lose weight,
and will help you fight
off sicknesses as well.
And as a special bonus, I'd say,
try adding some lemon to your water, too.
Adding some lemon to
your water in the morning
will give you vitamin C to
help boost your immune system,
will allow you to have better skin,
and will fight bad breath as well.
A good tip is if you're under 150 pounds,
add half a lemon to your water,
and if you're over 150 pounds,
add the full lemon into your water.
It makes a difference.
Stop reaching for coffee,
reach for water first.
(hip hop music)
Number three is music.
Music is so, so, so, so important,
because it changes your state.
When a good song comes on
that makes you want to bounce,
it instantly lifts your mood.
It instantly gives you more energy.
And so I have a Believe playlist,
and one of the things that
I do is every morning,
I wake up, and with my
wife, we put on a dance song
that we both enjoy, and
we dance, and we groove,
and we dance with each other.
It's a good time to bond,
but also to get us
shakin', to give us energy.
And so I would encourage you
to make your own playlist.
Think about songs that
make you want to move,
that make you just, when it comes on,
you have to bounce, you
have to get excited.
And start your day with that,
so that you have energy in the morning
after drinking your glass of water,
and you're ready to take on the day.
(hip hop music)
Number four is gratitude.
It's impossible to be
grateful for something,
and really sad, and depressed,
and angry at the same time.
And so I find it really helpful
to have a quick morning gratitude session
just to think about three things
that I'm grateful for, for the day.
And so it's something I do with my wife.
We'll wake up, we'll
grab a glass of water,
we'll then dance to a song,
and then we'll sit down for four minutes,
another song will come on,
it's calming, peaceful,
relaxing, no lyrics,
and we'll just put our
hand over our heart,
and think of three things
that we're grateful for,
for that day.
And I think that really helps set us up,
just the awareness, the
shifting of perspective,
the not complaining about the things
that are outside our control,
and just recognizing that we
have a lot of amazing things
that we have in our lives,
and not only focusing on the
things that we don't have.
For my view, it's not just
recognizing what's great,
it's also the frustration
that you want more, right?
Like I am equally happy with what I have,
I'm so grateful for it, and I want more.
I want to go out and have a bigger impact.
What I've done is not enough.
I don't want to just
rest on what's happened.
But if you only focus on this part
of wanting more, wanting
more, wanting more,
and not focusing on what you already have
and how great life is, then
you're never going to be happy.
And so I find that that combination
is really, really helpful.
(hip hop music)
Number five is review
your goals for the day.
I find it really helpful
to have a plan for the day.
And if you look at successful people,
they often have a plan.
They know their outcome for what they want
to accomplish for the day.
Again, if you don't have a plan,
you can guarantee that
everybody else around you
has a plan for you, right?
People have a plan for you.
If you open up your email,
there's a whole bunch of
people who have a plan for you,
and a plan for your time,
where you need to fight for that time,
you need to fight for what you want to do.
And so reviewing your
goals and remembering,
what am I trying to do today?
What's my outcome today?
What do I want to accomplish today?
And start setting up
walls for yourself to say,
nobody is going to crush
through these chunks of time,
because this is what I
want to get done today.
And so reviewing that in the morning,
reviewing that consistently,
reviewing that every day,
allows you to have a more powerful day
where you're more likely to
follow through on your goals.
If you can't remember what your goals are,
you're probably not going to
get them accomplished today.
(hip hop music)
Number six is exercise.
This is another way to
change your state, right?
If you're sleepy, and you're like this,
and you're complaining,
you're probably not going
to feel really powerful.
But if you get up, you drink some water,
you put on some music,
you do a quick exercise,
you do jumping jacks, you do some pushups.
For me I take my dog, Teemo, for a walk.
He's sittin' out here,
that's why I pointed.
You can't see him on
camera, but he's out here.
That's why I pointed to him.
Getting some kind of
exercise in the morning
gets your body movin',
gets the blood pumping,
gets things flowing,
even if it's 30 seconds of
jumping jacks, just something.
At the end of our walk, we'll
run up 13 flights of stairs,
and we'll both be panting and tired,
but I feel great, energized,
and ready to take on the day.
So adding some form of physical activity,
doesn't have to be half an hour walk,
could be 30 seconds of jumping jacks
at a high intensity just
to get the blood flowing,
will make a difference
to your energy level.
(hip hop music)
And number seven is be inspired.
It's really important.
I've talked about this a lot in my videos
to have an environment for success.
That whenever you felt
energized, excited, motivated,
bold, empowered, want to do great things,
what was it that caused that,
and put that into your daily routine?
So you have your goals, right?
We have your list of goals
that you want to accomplish,
you're reading those through,
but there's still that voice
in your head that will say,
you can't do that.
Who are you to think that
that's going to happen, right?
That's never going to happen for you.
You need the voice to say, I'm
going to crush these things.
Remember who you are.
These things are powerful.
You're going to go and kill it.
You can do this.
And so if it's watching a video,
or listening to a podcast,
or reading a book, or whatever it is,
however long it takes
you to get in that state
of feeling powerful, and unstoppable,
you want to do that daily.
So why I have the Entspresso
series in the morning,
as a video series to
help me get energized,
to be hanging around a
successful person for 10 minutes,
to give me a boost,
to not just give me a
strategy for what I can do,
but also just the motivation.
When you are around
other successful people,
you instantly become more successful.
When you're around hardworking people,
you instantly want to
start working harder.
If you're around lazy,
slow, apathetic people,
it's really hard.
You're going to become
lazy, slow, and apathetic,
where you know you have a higher gear,
you know you could play stronger,
you know you can go faster,
you know you can get up there.
So you need to design that environment.
You need to design that
into your morning routine,
so that you're living it daily.
So those are my seven ways on
how to start the perfect day.
I'd love to know, what did you think?
What did you learn from this video?
Which one was your favorite way?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Do you want to add an eight, nine,
10 that I haven't thought of?
I'd love to hear your thoughts.
Leave it below as well.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Marta Magdalena, Lifestyle Design.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and reviewing it,
making a video on your channel.
I really appreciate your support,
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(boom reverberates)